Too expensive, bad scripts, and a legacy nobody
wants to touch.
In sci-fi, anything is possible…except a
sequel to these films.
Tom Cruise is no stranger to sci-fi, having
starred in films such as Minority Report and
Edge of Tomorrow.
One that is often overlooked, however, is
2013's Oblivion.
Directed by Joseph Kosinski, Oblivion thoughtfully
explores ideas of isolation, love, and survival.
Not only is the movie visually stunning, but
it also includes the supporting talents of
Olga Kurylenko, Nikolaj Coster-Waldau, and
Morgan Freeman, and features a breathtaking
soundtrack composed by the French electronic
band M83.
Cruise plays Jack Harper, a technician who
lives on a remote base in a post-apocalyptic world.
He and his partner, Victoria, played by Andrea
Riseborough, are seemingly the only humans
on Earth and are tasked with protecting the
ruins of the planet from alien scavengers.
Harper believes that he and Victoria will
rejoin the remaining human colonists on Saturn's
moon once they have completed their objective.
However, as they go forward with their task,
Harper begins to quest ion who and what he
is, and if what he and Victoria are doing
is right.
"I don't know what happened, but you're not
who you think you are."
Oblivion does leave us with lots of questions
that could be expanded upon.
It's the kind of story that would really lend
itself to a prequel.
It would be interesting to see a film explore
how the war-ravaged Earth ended up this way,
and what Harper's life was like beforehand.
With Cruise still in great shape — and the
advancements of de-aging technology — a
prequel with the same cast wouldn't be out
of the question.
In the 2018 sci-fi film Upgrade, Grey Trace,
played by Logan Marshall-Green, is a mechanic
living in a futuristic world run by technology.
One day, he and his wife are attacked when
their hi-tech car malfunctions.
The thugs murder Grey's wife, and he is left
as a quadriplegic following damage to his spine.
Not helped by the trauma of what happened,
the previously anti-tech Grey suddenly becomes
completely reliant on it when he signs up
to be a test subject for an experimental technology
to help him walk again.
It works…but with some unintended side effects.
"I need your permission to operate independently."
"Permission granted."
"Thank You."
Upgrade shows what someone is capable of doing
when they're left with no choice, and the
film's ending leaves plenty of room for more
exploration.
The experiment leaves Grey as an overpowered
supercomputer with no empathy for humanity,
and this offers so much opportunity for a
sequel or franchise.
The good news is the filmmakers agree, and
Deadline announced in 2020 that director Leigh
Whannell and producer Jason Blum were turning
the movie into a television series.
Set a few years after the events of the film,
the series will focus on a new host, as well
as the ways that the government is using evolved
technology to deal with criminals and illegal activity.
It might not be an easy road to getting the
series made, however.
In 2021, Blum told Collider that the first
scripts didn't make the grade, saying,
"We're working on the scripts again, so that
we can get an order."
Since then, news has gone quiet about the
state of the project, but hopefully, it'll
get off the ground soon.
Directed by Josh Trank, Chronicle was a surprise
critical success and box office hit when it
was released in 2012.
The found-footage film takes the idea of a
superhero's origin story and flips it on its
head to tell us a villain's origin story instead
— delivering a film that is heartfelt, suspenseful,
and even uncomfortable at times.
Andrew Detmer, played by Dane DeHaan, is a
high school student who gets bullied by his
peers and father.
One day he — along with his cousin Matt,
played by Alex Russell, and popular jock Steve,
played by Michael B. Jordan — stumbles across
a meteor that gives them telekinetic powers.
At first, they use their abilities to enhance
their lives, however, as Andrew's suffering
grows, so does his need to take power.
Consumed by rage, he begins to see himself
as an apex predator and believes everyone
else is beneath him and should be destroyed.
Chronicle ends with Matt promising Andrew
that he'll do good works with his gifts.
But now that the world has seen their powers,
what will Matt do?
And how will Andrew's actions and death haunt
Matt into his adult life?
Only a sequel can answer that.
While screenwriter Max Landis had penned a
sequel, Trank didn't want to move ahead with it.
The director told Polygon,
"I really didn't ever want to see Chronicle
2 happen.
That was my worst nightmare."
Unless he has a change of heart, a follow-up
seems very unlikely.
Sci-fi series Firefly was something of a cult
hit when it was released, with Rotten Tomatoes
even naming it as the 12th best sci-fi series
of all time.
But the western themed space opera was unceremoniously
canceled after just one season in 2002.
Fortunately, the story picks up with the 2005
film Serenity.
The movie follows the same ragtag group of
outcasts on the Serenity spaceship, whose
lives get upended when River Tam, played by
Summer Glau — a woman with psychic powers
and a strange past — hides on board.
Unfortunately, not enough people watched it,
so the studio vetoed any more talk of sequels.
While diehard Firefly fans have been calling
out for more big-screen adventures for years,
they are yet to materialize.
Star Nathan Fillion told Entertainment Weekly,
"If I got $300 million from the California
Lottery, the first thing I would do is buy
the rights to 'Firefly,' make it on my own,
and distribute it on the Internet."
"So no more running.
I aim to misbehave."
In a later interview with Esquire, Fillion
said that this comment "accidentally rallied
the troops," as fans started raising money
for him to get the rights.
Going forward, he intends to be more careful
giving voice to his pipe dreams.
Audiences are used to seeing Tom Cruise play
the dashing hero, but 2014's Edge of Tomorrow
offers something new: The character he plays
is a bit of a coward.
Cruise plays PR officer, Major William Cage,
a man reluctantly thrust into a raging war
between humans and a seemingly unbeatable
race of aliens.
"Says here you're a deserter.
Says here you were caught impersonating an
officer."
At one point in a battle, Cage gets infected
with alien blood just before dying.
He miraculously wakes up 24 hours prior, seemingly
the only person with memories of his time
on the battlefield.
It's Groundhog Day meets an alien invasion
story, as Cage dies repeatedly in combat.
Forced to relive the same battle, he eventually
becomes a better fighter under the tutelage
of Emily Blunt's Sergeant Rita Vrataski, who
had previously held the same ability.
Talk of the next chapter of Edge of Tomorrow
began almost immediately and in 2016, director
Doug Liman told Collider that he had plans
to do a prequel.
In 2019, Entertainment Weekly confirmed that
an Edge of Tomorrow prequel was in development
at Warner Brothers but just two years later,
it ironically seemed to be stuck in a loop.
Emily Blunt told Entertainment Weekly in 2021
that she had read the treatment for Edge of
Tomorrow 2, saying,
"It was an amazing script, but I just don't
know what the future holds for it."
"Honestly, I think the movie's too expensive."
Robert Zemeckis' 1997 feature Contact, based
on Carl Sagan's novel of the same name, follows
Dr. Ellie Arroway, played by Jodie Foster,
a communications specialist who finds proof
of alien life.
Tasked with going to space in order to make
first contact with them, the journey challenges
her in ways she never anticipated.
Contact is a layered, philosophical story
that just happens to be sci-fi, as well.
It's not a big blockbuster action flick like
Independence Day.
Instead, it offers a slow build that leaves
you questioning the nature of life and what
it means to make true connections.
"They should have sent a poet.
So beautiful."
Jodie Foster is not an actor who likes to
do sequels — she famously passed on reprising
her role as Clarice in the sequel to Silence
of the Lambs — unless the plot is exactly
what she wants.
Since Contact is a movie she holds very close
to her heart, a sequel is unlikely.
Carl Sagan died while the film was in production.
Speaking to Vulture about him, Foster said
that,
"To be responsible in a way for the legacy
of Carl Sagan is really amazing to me.
That feels just like a really big deal in
my life."
"Until I sat down with Carl, I don't think
I really thought much about the vastness of
the universe."
A sequel to Contact isn't totally out of the
question.
Co-screenwriter Michael Goldenberg told Vulture
that he has a pitch for a limited series,
but so far, nothing has come from that.
Christopher Nolan likes to take audiences
on unexpected journeys, and his 2010 sci-fi
film Inception does just that.
The film plays around with dreams and how
they can be powerful motivators.
Although much of Inception feels like a heist
film, the story is ultimately about the lengths
a father will go to in order to be with his
family.
Leonardo DiCaprio plays Dom Cobb, a man wrongly
accused of murdering his wife.
"Do the children miss me?"
"I can't imagine."
To avoid arrest, he fled the country and hasn't
seen his children since.
Cobb works as an "extractor," using experimental
dream technology to infiltrate a person's
subconscious to extract information for his
clients.
When businessman Mr. Saito asks him to commit
to an impossible job and promises he can finally
return home to his children if he pulls it
off, Cobb agrees.
The ending of Inception is deliberately ambiguous.
Audiences never find out if Cobb is in the
real world with his kids or still in the dream world.
While it is an audacious way to end a film,
we'd love to learn more.
What about the rest of the characters?
If Cobb is trapped in a dream, how will it
affect them?
What happens if he wakes up?
Based on the book by Andy Weir, Ridley Scott's
2015 film The Martian stars Matt Damon as
botanist Dr. Mark Watney.
After finding himself stranded on Mars, Watney
is tasked with trying to survive while NASA
works on a rescue mission to bring him back
home.
Set in the year 2035, this sci-fi film offers
a fresh take on the genre, with a focus on
pure survival rather than the discovery of
alien creatures.
"In the face of overwhelming odds I'm left
with only one option: I'm gonna have to science
the s— out of this."
The biggest challenges Watney faces are finding
and rationing basic necessities like food
and water and trying to maintain his sanity.
The Martian was loved by audiences and critics
alike and it was nominated for a total of
seven Oscars, but it's unlikely that a sequel
will materialize.
However, the rights to Andy Weir's follow-up
novel Artemis, described as "an adrenaline-charged
crime caper," have been acquired by 20th Century
Fox and New Regency.
Akira imagines a post-apocalyptic world in
which Tokyo has become Neo-Tokyo, a dark place
filled with violence and corruption.
Shotaro Kaneda is the leader of a motorcycle
gang who discovers a group of people with
telekinetic powers living in Neo-Tokyo as
well as others who want to use that power
for their own means.
Akira introduces a bleak and violent world,
but one that is also thought-provoking and challenging.
Since its release, it's been the subject of
hyperbolic praise, with Dazed declaring it,
"The most important animation of all time."
While there have been numerous attempts to
turn Akira into a live-action movie — with
Warner Bros. first acquiring the rights in
2002 — so far, nothing has emerged.
The story presents a number of challenges,
but that's not to say people aren't trying
to bring it back.
Taika Waititi was the most recent director
tipped to do the live-action remake, but his
plans got pushed so he could do the Thor movies.
In 2021, Waititi told Wired he still wants
to do the film, saying:
"I'm still trying.
[...] I don't wanna give up on that."
Steven Spielberg's Ready Player One, adapted
from the Ernest Cline novel, brings together
nostalgia, pop culture, and a hugely enjoyable
adventure story.
In a dystopian future, people find solace
in the virtual reality game called "OASIS."
In the game, you can be whoever and whatever
you want.
Wade Watts is a lonely teenager who goes by
the name of "Parzival" in OASIS.
When the founder of the game dies, it's announced
that whoever can solve a puzzle and find the
golden key will become the new owner of the
game.
"If you're watching this, I'm dead."
Wade is determined to win and embarks on a
treasure hunt that takes him to places he
never dreamed of.
By the film's end, Wade makes a decision regarding
OASIS that changes the course of every single
person's life on the planet.
It's such a huge moment, and we'd love to
see what the repercussions of his decision
have on humanity.
Fortunately, a sequel to the novel, Ready
Player Two, was released in 2020, although
it was universally panned by critics.
Cline told Inverse that the feature film adaptation
of Ready Player Two is in the early stages
of development but time will tell whether
it will make it to the big screen given the
novel's poor reception.
As the debut feature from writer and director
Andrew Niccol, Gattaca is a pretty impressive
first offering.
The movie stars Ethan Hawke, Uma Thurman,
and Jude Law, and is a thoughtful exploration
of the meaning of life in an advanced society
that uses genetics to determine a person's
place in the world.
In the not-so-distant future, parents are
able to splice together the best part of their
genes to make a genetically superior child.
Anyone that's born the old-fashioned way is
considered to be inferior and given a lower
standing in society because of it.
Hawke portrays Vincent Freeman, one of those
unlucky children.
He meets the genetically superior Jerome Eugene
Morrow, played by Jude Law, a former Olympic
athlete who's become paralyzed.
The two decide to cheat the system, and Vincent
pretends to be Jerome.
"They won't believe that one of their elite
could have suckered them all this time."
With his now superior standing, Vincent gets
a job working at Gattaca as a navigator for
a space project to Saturn's moon.
The film ends with Vincent being allowed to
keep Jerome's life, and he leaves for his mission.
What happens to him and the world that's been
introduced is anyone's guess, but a sequel
— or even a prequel — could explore the
moral implications of genetic advances and
what it means for the people who get left
behind because of it.
Unfortunately, Niccol seems to have closed
the door on a sequel project.
In an interview with Fandom, he said,
"I don't know that there needs to be a sequel.
Once you've said it, do you need to say it
again?
We'll leave it to your imagination.
Better that you write the sequel in your mind
than I write it."
Starring Sigourney Weaver, Alan Rickman, and
Tim Allen, Galaxy Quest is a sci-fi cult classic
that everyone needs to experience.
While on the surface it looks to be a film
that just pokes fun at Star Trek, it really
is so much more than that.
It's a fun story about how fame and fortune
can ruin relationships, and sometimes you
just need a quick trip around the universe
to make things right again.
The film follows a group of actors from the
canceled sci-fi show, Galaxy Quest.
For the most part, the cast can't stand the
show's original lead — Jason Nesmith, played
by Tim Allen.
However, when a group of aliens abducts the
cast — believing what they've watched to
be fact rather than fiction — the actors
face the biggest challenge of their careers:
Being actual heroes.
"This is great.
You know, usually it's just cardboard walls
in a garage."
Star Trek is a franchise that seems to run
and run, so it is only right that Galaxy Quest
should receive the same treatment, especially
as the film ends with the cast getting their
show renewed.
Collider reports that Amazon Prime is poised
to revive Galaxy Quest as a television series,
however, following the tragic passing of Alan
Rickman, they paused their plans.
Weaver shares that if the revival series does
move forward, it will focus on a younger Galaxy
Quest cast joining forces with the remaining
original cast members for another adventure
in space.
When you talk about cult-classic sci-fi films,
no list is complete without 1997's The Fifth Element.
The film stars Milla Jovovich's as Leeloo
— the embodiment of the titular fifth element
— who must combine herself with the other
elements to stop "The Great Evil" from destroying everything.
Luckily, she falls into the cab of New Yorker
Korben Dallas, and he helps her on her journey
to save the world.
In many ways, The Fifth Element could be considered
as hugely ahead of its time, a sentiment with
which director Luc Besson agrees.
Besson points out that not only was the movie
more comedy than action, but it also had a
woman as the primary action star.
This combined with the outlandish costumes
designed by Jean-Paul Gaultier, and the decision
to have one of the main characters unable
to speak English, made the film a hard sell.
Audiences didn't quite know what to make of
it, and this was reflected in its disappointing
initial box office figures, which put a stop
to any talk of a sequel.
However, given audiences' receptiveness to
the weird and wonderful, and the subsequent
cult status of The Fifth Element, a sequel
would likely be welcome.
Just because Leeloo and Dallas saved the planet
once, doesn't mean that they can't do it again.
"What doesn't kill you makes you stronger."
Directed by Christopher Nolan, 2014's Interstellar
explores the possibilities of wormholes, time
displacement, and above all else, family.
It's an emotional tale of a father who leaves
his children in the hopes of giving them a
better life.
With food running out and the planet growing
closer to mass-level extinction, Earth can
no longer sustain humanity and so an alternative
place to live must be found.
"Find us a new home, and by the time you return,
I will have solved the problem of gravity."
Matthew McConaughey plays single dad, Cooper,
who is tasked with leading a team to find
a new habitable planet.
While Interstellar tells a beautifully poignant
story, it ultimately has a sad ending for Cooper.
When he eventually gets back home after many
years have passed, his young daughter is on
her deathbed.
"Nobody believed me, but I knew you'd come
back."
Interstellar ends with Cooper leaving once
more to find his mission partner, Dr. Amelia
Brand, who is still traveling alone in space
somewhere with no idea about what happened
to Earth and humanity.
A story about their adventures would be an
intriguing tale, especially after the success
that Interstellar enjoyed upon its release.
While doing the press tour for Interstellar
in 2014, McConaughey told Sky News that a
sequel was possible, but nothing has come
of it yet.
E.T. the Extra-Terrestrial is one of pop culture's
defining sci-fi films, from the director who
has made a number of such films in his career,
Steven Spielberg.
With the perfect blend of nostalgia, whimsy,
and effective storytelling, E.T is the blueprint
of how to make a successful family-friendly
sci-fi movie.
The film tells an emotional tale about a young
boy, Elliott, and his new alien friend, E.T.,
who finds himself stranded on Earth.
The two form a beautiful bond that transcends
species.
They connect over their shared experience
of feeling separate from their families.
Most of the adult characters in the film react
to E.T.
with fear and suspicion, but Elliott recognizes
the gentleness and good in him.
The film ends with E.T.
going home — which is his mission from the
beginning — but there is heartbreak on both
sides when he has to say goodbye to Elliot.
While the idea of seeing these beloved characters
in another feature would be welcome, it feels
like, if a sequel were going to come to light,
it would've happened already.
Following the success of E.T., the studio
did push the idea of a follow-up, but nothing
came of it.
Speaking to Slash Film about the possibility
of a sequel, actor Henry Thomas said:
"I think it should be left alone."
A reunion of sorts took place in 2019 featuring
some of the original cast — including Thomas
— reuniting with the lovable alien for a
holiday commercial.
The former child star went on to say,
"I think the commercial was as close as we're
going to get to a sequel and that's why Spielberg
okayed it."
What Galaxy Quest does for Star Trek, Spaceballs
does for Star Wars, offering an exceptionally
goofy take on the familiar tropes of the iconic
franchise.
While occasionally brutal in the way it pokes
fun at some of the more ridiculous plot points
in Star Wars, Spaceballs is a film that doesn't
take itself too seriously.
Its loving, carefree approach to its pastiche
is irresistibly charming.
The film follows the kidnapping of Princess
Vespa, who is being held hostage by Dark Helmet.
The Darth Vader-esque baddie holds her for
ransom in the hope of obtaining air, as his
planet has depleted its air supply.
Fortunately, she is rescued by bad boy space
pilot Lone Starr and his half-man, half-dog
partner, Barf.
Many fans of the film assumed that another
story was in the works, especially after Spaceballs
teased various titles for sequel films.
However, nothing has come out yet.
At a Q&A event in 2017, Mel Brooks talked
about the possibility of doing another film,
especially since the first movie became a
cult classic.
Unfortunately, as many of the original cast
members have now passed away, any new stories
would need to feature a new cast and be told
in a way that would honor those who came before.
While technically, Dredd is a reboot of the
1995 film Judge Dredd starring Sylvester Stallone,
the 2012 film bears very little resemblance
to the previous movie and they appear to be
connected in name and title character only.
As the only film in its particular universe,
2012's Dredd earns a place on this list.
In a dystopian city called Mega-City One,
the judges have the power to act as judge,
jury, and executioner.
Dredd, played by Karl Urban, takes rookie
Cassandra Anderson, played by Olivia Thirlby,
with him to a 200-story apartment to investigate
a murder.
The building is controlled by a violent drug
lord named Ma-Ma, played by Lena Headey.
She's a formidable foe, but she meets her
match in Judge Dredd.
"But as for you, Ma-Ma, judgment time."
Critics praised Dredd and fans have turned
it into a cult classic, but the movie failed
to recoup its $50 million budget with a meager
worldwide haul of $41 million.
While the 2018 comic Dredd: Final Judgment
is an official sequel to the film, we have
yet to see anything new on-screen.
Olivia Thirlby expressed her enthusiasm for
a Dredd sequel, telling Collider in 2021,
"I was always the number one advocate of getting
a sequel for Dredd.
[...] If there is still talk of there being
a sequel 10 years later, I am all for it."
2002's Minority Report has an incredible amount
of talent both in front of and behind the
camera, with Tom Cruise in the leading role
and Steven Spielberg in the director's chair.
Cruise plays Chief John Anderton, the commanding
officer of the Precrime Unit, an experimental
prototype program designed to stop murders
before they happen.
Initially, John wholeheartedly believes in
Precrime, until he witnesses a murder that
he's about to commit in the future.
Once John starts investigating, he uncovers
damaging evidence regarding the supposedly
fool-proof unit.
The premise for Minority Report is instantly
engaging, and it feels like a story that could
expand into a franchise or multiple installments.
"I'm sorry John, but you're going to have
to run again."
The Precrime unit uses the special abilities
of three humans called "precogs," who have
the ability to see the future and witness
crimes before they happen.
With their skills proven to be fallible, it
opens up a number of questions about them
that a sequel could address.
One of the rare exceptions on this list, Minority
Report was brought back as a television show,
airing in 2015.
The story takes place a little over 10 years
after the film and follows one of the precogs
who still retains their ability.
Unfortunately, the series was canceled by
Fox after just one season, but there's still
room for the story to continue on the big
screen.